hello everyone I'm excited to join you
all and learn and teach more about how
to use snowflake to go from raw data to
an interactive data application or you
can also call it the other way around as
to how are we going to build an
interactive data application from raw
data by building an end to endend data
and ml pipeline which is what we're
going to go do
today before we get into the workshop
just a little bit about me I am V now
and I started as a software engineer and
then pivoted into the data space I
worked as a data and ml engineer in
different companies Nike and net app and
apple and more and then currently I work
as a developer Advocate at snowflake
focusing on the data engineering and the
Machine learning workloads of course and
you can follow my work primarily on
medium where I talk about all things
State Engineering and AI specifically
about llms these days which are kind of
hogging the Limelight all the time and
follow me on medium if you want to read
more about them and what it means to be
a data engineer in the age of llm and
more now for the workshop today this is
broadly what it looks like the agenda we
will start with you know understanding
what the prerequisites are how to
install them and setting up the lab and
everything just ready for us to go use
the snowflake tool and then I will walk
you through a little bit about an
overview of what is snow park and how do
you do this end to end workflows with
snow park so it's nothing fancy it has
three different modules to it you can do
data engineering with snow park and then
ml modeling and also the mlops stuff
with snow park so after learning about
all the three different components to it
we will straightly you know dive into
the Hands-On lab where we will build an
Intero Pipeline and then in the end I
will leave some time you know out for
our questions and also talk about what's
new in Snowflake which is all llm
support and
more with that said let's get into the
prerequisites and since we all tuning in
online from our own homes I'm assuming
that we would have a good internet
connection to download all the
prerequisites that people would need
first thing I want us all to go to Quick
starts. snowflake. comom where you will
find tons of quick starts about how to
get started with different snowflake
features today we're going to be
focusing on building an end to end ml
workflow so we will go over the intro to
ml with snow park ml for python quick
start and then the quick starts at
snowflake are just like stepbystep
instructions that will help you go from
like absolute scratch all the way to the
data product that you want to build and
if you are able to go to Quick starts.
snl.com Search for machine learning and
you will be able to see the one that's
highlighted and that is the quick start
we're going to walk through today and
I'm going to explain every step and
every line of code in there to make us
all understand what like how you can use
snow park to build an end to an ml
workflow this is how it looks in the you
know these are the different steps we
have in the quick start and in the
prerequisites we would expect you to
have a git installed and you know
anaconda or any other package management
system but if you already have anakonda
that's cool but if you don't you can
click on the you know links there they
will take you to the install
instructions so get an anaconda if you
don't have it already please you can you
know follow the quick links and install
it now and of course the the latest not
the latest probably the latest is 311
but then as long as you have 39 of
python we good to
go and before I dive into the
presentation I want as folks to go
install the git Anaconda and Python and
suppose you already have them you know
feel free to tell me in the comments
that you already have them installed so
I can move forward and we don't have to
waste time on getting
us the installation steps I'm just
looking out in the chat if we already
have it do you have git anaconda and
python versions already installed on
your
system gotcha I see that some of us are
getting anakonda installed it'll take a
couple of minutes
which will we will go over our
presentation so that gives us enough
time to get all these installations done
meanwhile and of course we're all data
practitioners here and some of you might
already have python G and anaconda and
some of you you might even have
snowflake install so that's all
good
and I will also share the link to this
quick
start so you can refer to it in cas
[Music]
case awesome all right let's Dive Right
into to the
presentation when I'm talking about
building interactive data application
from raw data what what are the steps in
between and what are the challenges in
each of these steps as of today like in
the current existing tools tag today
one of the biggest differences between
building an ml workflow or a data
application versus a simple software
application is that a software
development life cycle is very linear
you you know develop locally test it
deploy it monitor it and then it's done
it's just very linear but when it comes
to the ml or you know any data
engineering pipelines it's just very
iterative because what happens we have
this data engineering team who pulls in
the you know raw data for us and does
edl Transformations and curates the data
curates the training data for the ml
team and then the machine learning team
or the data science team it takes that
data works on it experiments with
different features different model
algorithms and try to arrive at an
efficient model for whatever metric
they're optimizing for and what happens
if they don't if some of the experiments
are not successful we go back to the
data team and ask for let's say updated
set of data and then we try on that with
new features algorithms and whatnot and
optimization
parameters so this back and forth and
back and forth keeps happening until the
data science team arrives at an
effective model but then even after they
arrive at that model the deployment part
of it either goes to an mlop team if
there is a separate mlops team sitting
in the data like within the or or it
typically is also done by data Engineers
because building a data Pipeline and an
ml train tring pipeline are kind of very
similar so what happens it starts with
the data team goes to the science team
and then for deployment it goes back to
the engineering team again and then in
the end it is being consumed by an end
team which is like a business or like
you know analytics team that consumes it
so the workflow is not at all linear
it's very itative in nature and because
of this there is a lot of context that
gets lost if you are a data engineer or
a data person you would have had this
experience where someone from the data
science team be like can you pull this
data for me done what for in what
context is it being used or what
business case is it solving for that
data science team we don't have a lot of
insight into that and if you're a data
science person you will be like how hard
can it be to just pull the data it's
already there why is it taking so many
days or so many hours and you don't have
full understanding of the infrastructure
and the challenges with the data
infrastructure and because of this loss
of context it becomes extremely
difficult to work with these different
teams and the other comp like you know
the other challenge is not just this
loss of context but also that the data
is siloed within each for example data
engineering is working with their own
copies of data with local and staging
and Brad and then they share the pr data
to the data science team and if there
are multiple team people in the data
science science they create their own
copies for their local development and
then they have their own concept of you
know Dev and staged and PR and in this
process we create multiple copies and
silos of data there there are sitting
across in different you know
environments Dev staging and
PR to solve this is why you know
snowflake in fact snow park is helping
us and how does it help us in each of
these phes like how does snow park help
you with data engineering ML and all the
ml op stuff of it so let's start with
data engineering and I will explain how
snow park helps with this data silos
primarily what happened was before snow
park came into existence snowflake was a
simple cloud data warehouse it used to
be and we only used SQL to do our data
engineering tasks data transformations
to write our ETL you know
Transformations and whatnot and then to
do our data science work or to write our
python code we used external compute so
what happened as you can see here is the
data team is working with the snowflake
data that is sitting in Snowflake using
SQL but the data science team is
creating copies of that data into
external computer environments and then
working off of that data to build their
data science models and there is a lot
of data movement out and back to
snowflake which is not a great thing to
do if you're working with truly Big Data
environments moving the data in in out
of where it is is the least you know
effective optimal thing to do so how
what can you do about it is what if you
can bring the M ml or the data science
component or the python component into
the snowflake so now you can keep the
data where it is but all the different
teams can bring their code and compute
to where the data is so that's what
happened after snowflake I mean after
snow park so snow park is a set of you
know libraries it it allows you to write
code in Java Python and scale and Scala
and so if you have snow park in there
what happens is all the external compute
is happening within Snowflake and now
there is no data movement in an out of
snowflake at all so what happens is your
data engineering team data science all
of them are working off of that one
single copy of data that is sitting
within
snowflake so there are no data silos
there are no 10 different copies of data
sitting around inside Snowflake and
outside Snowflake and it's just a mess
not there
anymore but if there is just one single
copy of data that every team is using
how is it even efficient aren't they all
going to mess up that single copy of
course not because we are familiar with
zero copy cloning where you can create
multiple development environments off of
the same data by using the zeroc copy
cloning feature which snow park and
snowflake offers so using that we all
working off of the same data but with
our own know cloned copies but there are
zero copy clones meaning it's not an
entire clone of all of your data set but
just the
changes okay so now if we go back to our
challenges the data silos and different
teams working with different copies of
data was one of the biggest challenges
and we solved that by bringing SQL I
mean by bringing the compute and the
python Java scalar code to the data
instead of moving the dataa and
now all right so the data Silo problem
is solved and the collaboration like you
know how is this context getting lost
between one to another how long is it
going to pull the data from how long is
it going to take for the data team to
pull the data that data science team is
looking for all of that will be solved
as well if everyone in the team is
working with just one language what I
mean by that is if I'm a data science
person writing python code working with
pyit learn and nltk and XG boost and
whatnot to build my ml model I'm
dependent on the data engineer to bring
me the data the training data that I
need but if the data engineering team is
using spark for
example that is going to be a bottleneck
for me because I
cannot it's it's hard for a data science
person to go start writing a spark job
to reduce the dependency on the data but
what if everything is in Python both
data engineering data science and even
the Ops of it all in Python so it makes
this interoperability within the teams
super convenient and there is no loss of
context or like this external dependency
within the data
teams and with all the problems solved
but can we just understand how snow park
actually works what is it and like dive
a little bit into under the hood of what
snow park looks like like I said before
snow park is just a set of libraries and
compute and what do I mean by libraries
like if you you're a python developer
you know like pandas and numai and pyit
learn and all of those are external
libraries and snow park also has similar
you know libraries that you can use and
it comes with you know two different API
sets one is the data frame API for the
data engineering and the ml API ml
modeling and the ml operations API for
the machine learning side of it so since
the entire data team is working with
snow park it's super easy to work with
you know if you're working with ML
modeling API it's super easy for you to
pick up the data frame API and pull the
data yourself reducing the
dependency and then on the you know
server side it also comes with a bunch
of compute and as I said traditionally
snowflake only had this SQL compute
engine and it was only able to you know
process the SQL queries but currently
thanks to snow park it is also now able
to you know process non-sql code it
could be python Java rcala within the
same compute engine as well so it's just
that and and another interesting
component is with all the llms and
generative AI coming in you will now
also have access to the container
services which means container services
are a way for you to get GPU compute to
run all your llm workloads and more so
it's
just the servers that run times are just
a bunch of compute clusters but then you
could be using standard warehouses as
compute clusters or container services
as GPU compute clusters based on your
workload but then overall the you know
summary of this is that with snow park
we are able to work like the data
engineering data science and the op team
are all able to work off of the single
set of apis the snow park apis that will
help you do everything end to end by
yourself and how does it work and when
I'm talking about a data frame query you
write a simple data frame and you know
like API and that gets you know pared
and translated and you know formulated
into a SQL query plan which is now run
on the SQL engine which is super easy
when you think about a simple data frame
operation it's very functional but when
you go think about so if I'm using psyit
learn for example you cannot run or you
cannot convert every pylon function into
a SQL query plan so how is snow park
going to run them snow park is going to
convert the external libraries into a
python bite code and then run them into
a python like in a python sandbox and
that's how it's going to run the non
data frame
API and it also has support for like the
snow park ml has support for a bunch of
ml libraries and data frame also has
support for external libraries like
numai pandas and SK and like psychic
learn and caras and more one of the
biggest questions that I get asked in
this slide specifically is if I'm
already using psyit lar or pandas or
numai why would I have to use them again
within snowflake like how does it matter
or what is the difference the biggest
differentiating Factor here is that if
you're using let's say pandas and pylon
and numpy to build your ml workflow they
do not have like native built-in
parallelism enabled and if you're using
the same packages but within
snowflake because of you know snow parks
optimization that is being done all of
these packages all of these functions
are run internally within snowflake in a
distributed fashion so like paralyzing
the same functions just for optimization
purposes is how snowflakes version of
these packages are different from the
actual pandas and
numai and now we already test on a bit
about you know the data engineering
stuff so let's quickly dive into the ml
like the modeling apis and how you can
use
them and when we think about machine
learning it the offerings vary like
drastically on a spectrum so you could
be using an snowflake cortex function to
just say create summaries of a specific
colum on your data and all the way to
let's say you can even build like a
proprietary custom llm on all of your
snowflake data that is sitting in
already so it like the offerings vary
like almost on the Spectrum you could
use snowflak C cortex functions in a
second and all the way to building your
own proprietary llm but in between is
where most of our ml you know use cases
today sit and we have notebooks and
featur store and modeling apis and the
mlops API which is Snow Park Model
registry and we also have for the
consumption streamlit like you can use
streamlet in Snowflake to build any
visualization app
as a you know front end for your ML
workflows and in today's like workshop
for example we're going to be using the
ml modeling API and the model registry
and just to show how it works and how
you can use them as part of your
workflow and other llm stuff is probably
out of scope of this Workshop but then
in the end I will give you some
resources so if you are interested in
building something with Snowflake and
llms you will have some resource to to
get
started
and again in the compute layer if you
look at it there are like two different
types of compute one standard compute
and the other is the GPU compute powered
in like GPU powered compute instances
and even in the standard compute there
are like two different types one is like
a standard virtual Warehouse you can use
for data engineering workloads and snow
park optimized Warehouse which you can
use for the machine learning workloads
that are training
heavy and we have in G a today which is
snow park ml modeling
API I think last as of the 5th of
December the modeling apis are available
in GA which means we will now be able to
use all the modeling functions in your
ml workflow even in
production and I think we've already
touched upon a bit what does you know
Snow Park look like it's a set of client
side libraries and server side run times
the client side it has different apis it
supports like in the modeling I will
primarily classify them into
pre-processing library and the model
training library and in the compute of
course we talked about how having a SQL
engine and a python sandbox allows you
to run both the SQL code and non-sql
code within
snowflake okay so currently for the ml
modeling API we have support for these
like the most popular pre-processing
functions and the most Pro the most
popular psychic learn models and XG
boost models for your
use we've talked so much about data
engineering and the actual ml modeling
content so what about the ml Ops what
about you know where to deploy the model
how to store different versions of the
model and even like you know keep tab of
all the different metadata that is
associated with each of these models
which is where the model registry comes
in with snow park model registry which
is currently in
preview you can
store snowflake trained models or you
can also store any of these externally
trained models like Lo log them as part
of your model registry and then deploy
them and then use it it's a simple
twostep process in your existing
workflow just log an already already
trained model into a registry just
deploy it to whichever compute you want
depending on what model that is and
you're good to
go just to you know give you a quick
understanding of how you are able to
create a model registry you know log a
model and then deploy it all in like
five lines of code and that's how easy
it is to get started with model registry
easy to use super secure because this
entire workflow is now sitting within
snowflake okay so this is how the
endtoend ml workflow within snowflake
looks like so you have the TA engine ing
team who is using the data frame apis on
standard virtual Warehouse to prepare
and transform your training data and
then you pass it on like you pass on the
training data to the data science team
who runs their own you know ml
experiments using snow park optimized
warehouses because it's an ml workload
and they will be using ml modeling API
to you know build and train these ml
models and then comes the next part
which is the deployment or the Ops side
of it where we have the model registry
where the data science team will log
their successful models which then the
Ops team will use to deploy it into an
inference endpoint and then you know our
customers or internal business users in
the end using these you know models from
the registry to make predictions out of
it by having this entire workflow sit
within snowflake we are avoiding the
data silos that we talked about and
second there is no loss of context
because now even as a data science
person you will be able to take a Peak
at what the data engineering workflow
looks like and more so you can
understand what happens in each of these
faces there is no loss of context
between the teams and the the entire
data and the workflow sits within
snowflake within snowflakes security and
the governance boundary meaning like
especially for mlu cases there is tons
of data privacy regulations and
governance restrictions and you don't
have to worry about any of that because
the data sits in the snowflakes security
and governance
boundary all right I think we've talked
enough so let's go ahead and write some
cod and I'm going back to the same thing
in case you know we did not get our
hands on the quick start quick starts.
snowflakes. quick starts. snowflake.
comom you go to the machine learning one
and this is that specific quick start
that we wanted to you know have a look
at and the quick start had a bunch of
prerequisites not sure
if I think I'll take a
quick I I'll I'll have a quick pause
here for
folks if you are able to you know get
everything set like get and anacon and
python
installations and I'll give it a minute
break and then we'll get
started okay can you quickly let me know
in the chat if you already have all of
these you know dependencies installed in
your
local and if you are done with you know
installing gon anak and python you can
also get a snowflake free trial
account so let me go over those steps
again I think
okay you can go to the snowflake free
trial at sign up. snowflake.
comom and and you can just enter your
details and make sure in the second
screen that pops up that you want to
select the Enterprise I mean you can
select anything like the standard one or
the business critical one too
because we are not really going to use
any of these Enterprise features today
but then that's the standard one you can
just stick to that but then for the
cloud service providers we're going to
be using AWS so you can select AWS for
that and then you should be able to get
a couple of emails first is to activate
your account and once you activate it
you will get the details of your
specific account and I want you to you
know take a note of this account
identifier from your emails that you
will
get mm I see some question question s
will this work with python 311 yes it
will but then in the code repo like in
the GitHub repo we in the K I think K
environment that yam I will be using the
3.9 to create a new K environment feel
free to update the 3.9 to 311 and then
you will be able to create a new K
environment for
sure just make sure to update the config
and you will be able to run the rest of
the world work
shop and I also see a bunch of questions
are there any performance implications
or costs incurred as a result of data
frame
translations to SQL queries in
Snowflake not at all actually if you
think about all the data frame
operations like the data frame apis and
the SQL you know translations they're
very much like one to one mapped and
it's it's very much the same in even in
the other languages if you can think of
so so there there is not a loss of
efficiency or optimization in fact the
other way around because now we using
snowflakes proprietary SQL optimization
like SQL engine to run our data frame
apis it would work out even better for
us
mm and all
right are are you all able to create
this s free trial account as well can
you just let me know in the comments so
I know if you're able
[Music]
to Meanwhile while folks are waiting for
the others to catch up on creating this
I have a quick poll just to
understand
how like who are we today like who are
what is each of our responsibilities and
what are we doing with our work and why
are we here today so this just a quick
poll on like which part of the data
Spectrum we fall into Data engineering
data science mlops or anything
else oh
okay I see a lot of data science folks
so I did a good job today focusing on
the ml
stuff it's almost a one-sided game
against data science today
oh someone started the analytics game
that's
cool I think I'll give it one more
minute for folks to create the snowflake
free trial account as
well and then we'll get started with the
actual
workflow
all right okay so I'm assuming that we
were able to create
the snowflake trial and move
forward okay we will not do this now
let's go
back okay once you're done with
the free trial I want us to open the
terminal and in your terminal you can
just clone this K
repository
and you might already see that in the
quick start they would have also mention
that you need to clone this kit
repository which is where we have our
code for today to walk
through and once you're done with that
you can go ahead and create a new K
environment as well I
guess quickly going over this we have
the prerequisites we have the snowflake
free trial we have to set up the
environment we've not logged into the
snowflake account yet so let's just keep
that on the
side and okay so download the git
repository and then go ahead and create
the K environment and activate this one
as
well and someone was asking if they can
work with python 311 go and update this
KL with python 311 so it will use that
version to create this new
environment and once you're done with
this setup we can go back to
snowflake
are you able to okay I'm going to the
snowflake in my assignment
partner I was able to log to snowflake
account and once you are able to log in
the first thing I want you to do is go
to admin billing and
terms and enable the anakonda python
packages in here I've already enabled
but you need to enable this one to run
anything like any of those packages from
Snowflake
and once you're done with that go to
worksheets create a new SQL
worksheet and in the new SQL worksheet
you can copy this entire
setup queries that we have and you could
just run them all together I'm just
going to run I guess just the first
[Music]
part okay so it created everything
successfully I can go to the mlh
DB I have the schema
stages assets all of them
create and now let's go ahead and create
the file format I'm just creating the
CSV file format because my input data is
in the CSV format and I want snowflake
to be able to read these CSV files from
staging so just create this file format
for
that and then here is where our ual you
know raw data sits in it's in an S3
bucket so I'm going to create a new
stage to load this data using the CSV
format we just created and let's see
what
happens all right so the other stage the
staging area Diamond assets is created
but it's an external stage not the
internal one and let's just list what's
in the diamond assets we'll be able to
see just the CSV file from your
awesome so there is the CSV file great
it's just that setting up whatever infra
that we will need and we created a new
Warehouse which is the compute and we
created a database just a logical
container to store all our data just a
schema again and created a stage to
store our models which we will train
later in the workflow
and that's pretty much it once we're
done with the setup we could skip to the
next
part which is the python setup which I
also assume we were able to run can you
let me know in the comments if you're
able to run this entire
thing mhm okay so the first thing is you
can create this K environment and after
you're done you can even like you know
spin up this Jupiter notebook but after
you do the Jupiter notebook part you
will have you know jupyter notebook
running in your local Port
8888 and you also have this setup. SQL
which has exact same files like exact
same commands that we ran to set up
person SN
account
and folks who wanted to update you can
also update the 31 here and you will be
able to install everything in here
and the next step being you need to
update your connection J Json with all
the details and in this one excuse me
and for this one the warehouse database
Keyon even the roles are pre-populated
but then you need to use your account
identifier and the username and password
for the free trial account here and
remember for the account identifier you
can go to your snowflake account and
then then when you click on
your you know on the bottom left you
will have this account name and you
click on this account name and it will
let you copy this account identifier as
well but the interesting thing is when
you do copy this
account let's say I'm just going
to if you copy the account identified
it's going to have this first part dot
the second part but you need to make
sure that it's a hyphen not a DOT and it
will it will let you run through
everything else
smoothly or you can also find your
account identifier from the email that
you would have
got just remember to replace the dot in
between with a hyen otherwise it would
not let you run through
this and once you're able to
update your connection Json we are good
to go
and there are like three worksheets I
mean like three Jupiter notebooks here
the first one being the data inje and
transformation like the data engineering
part the second is the feature
engineering and the third is the ml
model training and deployment we will
just you know walk through these three
different python notebooks and if you're
familiar with python you will be able to
run through them by yourself too but
let's just you know get started with
data ingestion the first is of course
you know a bunch of libraries that we
have that we're importing and as you can
see here I am importing snow park
Python and like within the Snow Park
Library you see there are different
types that are supported and you can use
the functions from there as well and I'm
also using the external Library which is
numai and I also have Json to load the
Json data as well just in case so if I'm
able to run that successfully it runs
fine okay let me do
this so it's easy for us to go through
each
steps I'm able to import all the
libraries needed this sow Park Library
primarily and then the first thing is
I'm opening the connect the connection
Json that we just updated to read all
the connection parameters and use that
to build the snowflake session and once
I have that let's try to print you know
all the session details as you can see
what is your username role and all the
snowflake objects that we have created
snowflake version and the python version
as well like snow park python version
and we are able to connect successfully
but H okay so I see a question where do
I find the worksheet to set up the data
I don't seem to have that on my S Park
you will not find it's it does not come
pre-baked you have to go create this new
SQL worksheet and then copy the code
from the setup snowflake environment and
run
that all right so let's go to our flow
if you're able to connect to the Json I
mean if you're able to connect to the
snowflake account like the snowflake
instance and then the rest of the you
know modules done
smoothly and as you saw before we had
the diamonds. CSV which was from an
external S3 bucket and we created an
external stage for that and you could
simply you know like Read that read the
data from the external stage just like
if you're familiar with spark or even
pandas like P spark or pandas you will
know this format is very similar like
very similar instead of pd. read CSV
you're doing like session. read.csv and
give all the options that you want to
give and in this case I want to iner the
schema and pass the header as well and
it's pretty much it let's see what the
data looks like for
now um okay so these
are the different columns that I have so
it's a diamonds data set so we have
different attributes of diamonds in
these columns and in the output which is
like the dependent variable is the price
so we're going to predict the target
variable which is price here depending
on all the other input
columns and let's just you know look at
how much like how many records do we
have what are the different Min and Max
for each of these columns and more the
formatting is not the best here but I
see there are about 54,000 rows and
there are like this Min and Max for each
of these columns and let's just like you
know I see a lot of these null values
here as well so let's go ahead and do a
bit of cleaning here the first part of
the cleaning being I would clear up the
you know table names and just make them
you know upper case for snowflake to
store these values so I'm just looking
at the column like the column names and
making them upper case just to make it
look cleaner it's nothing to do with the
data cleaning per se but then in here as
you see there are like different values
for the cut column how do you see that
if you go into the cut you see it's a
categorical variable with different
names to it and I'm just trying to make
them all like a single variable so later
I can use the dummy you know variable
encoding for the feature Transformations
so I'm just you know clubbing them all
into just one word or like I don't want
multiple words in the cut category so
I'm just going to you know replace the
space with an
underscore so how would this look like
like for
me hm
interesting mhm okay so what I'm doing
is I'm taking the diamonds DF data frame
that we have here and then I pass cut
column like I pass the input column cut
and I want that column to be fixed like
I want this column is input to the fixed
values function and then the output of
that will be captured here and as you
can see if you look at cut we are able
to replace the space like anything other
than these alpha numeric characters with
an underscore so which has done its job
well
awesome and this is let's say is the
first level of you know just cleaning up
the data and making sure it looks okay
and let's also look at what the you know
data types for each of these columns
look like and like some of these are
nullable not nullable what do they look
like and as I can see carrot is of
decimal type h there is there are a
bunch of strings and decimal types and
long types I say and one of the caveats
is currently snow parkl does not support
the decimal type so I'm going to convert
them all into the double and so I'm just
going
to you know convert all these columns
from decimal to the double and then see
what that looks like and as you can see
I was able to convert all of them into
double great so let's just keep this as
some sort of a clean data which we were
able to get for our training and let's
just write this data back into a new
table called diamonds but if you
currently look at your snowflake like
sorry about that so currently we don't
have any tables our data was in the
stage if you remember it was in the
external stage the CSV
file okay so this pretty much it we
don't have any T like tables at all so
let's go ahead and create this table and
then let's go have a look at the table
then I don't want the stage but if I
look
at
oops
sorry ah okay so I have the table which
is the diamond stable and let's have a
look at what it looks like it should
look very similar
to what we had okay this color Clarity
cut and as you see it's all like single
column and
then all the way up to all the other
columns as
well and if you look at the you know
column details you will see you know
there is like the double type which is
the float and then the others are just
Vare cares and numbers awesome so we
have everything and it looks good so
let's switch on to the ml stuff which is
like the feature engineering part so now
we'll move to the feature
Transformations and again very similar
we have a bunch of Snow Park Imports for
you know the functions and the data
types and here is where the modeling API
comes in and you can use the snowflake
modeling like the snow park modeling API
to do the pre-processing and build an
entire Pipeline and also do the
correlation and other statistical like
you know metrics like numbers that you
want to run just to explore your data so
these are snow park ml related and these
are standard data science libraries if
you're familiar with I'm just just going
to be using some of them you know for
our let's say just to plot some things
and
more and of course the rest of these
import files here so I just imported
everything that we need for
this and the connection would already
been successful we already connected it
so there is nothing new here and let's
just so for the rest of this notebook I
want to use the specific DB in the
schema so I'm just setting the scope in
here and once that is done we have the
diamonds table and I'm trying to read
the diamonds table into my notebook
which is our now training data and so
once you run through
this very similar to what we saw in
the you know snowflake UI nothing
different really so let's get into the
actual fun stuff which is the feature
Transformations so when we do a describe
again as we can see that you know what
is the count mean standard deviation and
Min and Max of some of these columns and
let's look at the carot column for
example the minimum value of carat that
we see in these 54,000 records is 02 and
the max is five and as with anything
else if you're doing a simple linear
regression or like let's say even here
today we will be using XG boost as well
so let's start with how do we you know
normalize these specific column values
and I'm using a Max scaler to normalize
and if you are familiar with minmax
scaler from pylon Library you know that
you can in
it's the minmax scaler from snow park is
very similar to the psychic learn one
and it's even more convenient because it
abstracts away a lot of these
complexities you don't have to worry
about what should the output column
names be what should the input columns
names be and like there is nothing
really you just Define the input and you
want a minmax scaling and then then
Define the output and then you create
like you get this output
column like it's it's very
simple and if you remember in pyit learn
you would have to create this new column
and then drop the previous column and
you also have an option do you want to
drop it do you not want to drop it and
there's just like a tons of I guess
boiler plate that we do but here it's
just super simple for
you and you take the input carot column
and then you normalize it into carat NM
and that's it and then you fit and
transform that on your data set and
great this looks good so now let's go
ahead and see but you can see that the
carrot column has the same Min and Max
but then the carrot n has this zero and
one as the standardized
variables like the standardized values
and once we done with that what do we
want to do here clearly as you can see
the cut is a categorical way variable
but I cannot use them as is so I'm just
trying to like you know encode them into
using a one heart or ordinal
encoder and if you look at these
categories that we have there are some
columns that needs to be ordinal because
it means something different to have an
ideal or premium cut versus a fair cut
so these values should be in an order
and they the order means something
whereas in the other columns say for
example like in this one like cut and
Clarity although they are of
different uh different values like
different categorical values the orders
matter so much so you do need to keep
the ordinal encoder for these two
columns and then the color not really so
much does is one color better than the
other it are are they inherently like
different these different categories not
really so you can leave them to a one
hard encoder as well so for let's say
for the ordinal encoder part I'm just
going to use the cut and the clarity
columns and I Define the order as well
so you define which values are you know
better than the other so you rank them
in the order of what is like what is
better and then same with the clarity as
well and once you have that you pass the
input columns to the ordinal encoder and
expect these output columns and you fit
and transform on your data set and then
you will have the updated data set like
the ordinal encoded data data frame here
just for us to have a peak into what
does it look like how each of these
categories are indexed in these encoder
so I'm just like when you print this
using you know the state pandas
function it would show you for each
column name and category what is the
corresponding index so this is helpful
to just see how each of these categories
were mapped in index forms as
well and in the end you can also use the
one hot encoder to transform these
categorical columns into numeric columns
for example color did not really have
any ordinal function so you could just
use an a color as a one hot encoding
like you can pass color into a one hot
encoder and do that but in this case
I've just used this one hot encoder just
to show you but I will not be using that
in the
actual ml model as at all because I if I
remember correctly cut and Clarity are
ordinal values so I put them in ordinal
encoders not into categorical this is
just to show you that you can use one
hot encoder as
well and in the end so let's put them
all together and build a pipeline so
these are my categorical columns
and what are my the outputs of these
ordinal encoders are these and what are
the numerical columns I have these
numerical columns and for all the
categorical columns I also need these
orders mentioned so I'm mentioning them
in whatever order that I you know
correct for the specific column and here
is the pipeline function it's very
similar to SK learn like pyit learn
pipeline again you can Define your
entire pre-processing and like you know
standardizing and normalizing and actual
training pipeline so here we only have
two pre-processing functions one is the
audal encoder and the other as the min
max scaler for the carrot column so once
you do that you can Define your pipeline
file as a jobb and then you know add it
to the stage as well so let's just you
know if you run this you know
pre-processing Pipeline and fit it on
our diamonds data frame you will see
that you know all the scaled up like and
standardized values are here and it's
kind of hard to make sense of some of
these data because now it's all like
numerically
encoded but let's go ahead and you know
save the preo the pre-processing
pipeline file into our stage as well but
once we oh I have to run through the
entire steps to do
that
[Music]
okay we were able to build the pipeline
okay so now let's go ahead and check in
our
stages do we see a
preprocessing tables
stages
whoops
[Music]
so where is any mlh oil assets oh okay
so we already have this mlh o assets but
we don't see it
let's H
interesting maybe it takes a few seconds
let's get back to it in a bit and then
so once once we have all the data
processing done what does like data
pre-processing done what does the actual
data set look like so this is how it
looks everything
is like we were able to write that the
pre-processing JP pipeline into the
stage and now we will read this the
pre-processed data frame like the
transform data frame and try to do a
simple correlation and see what it looks
like right and it's a bit hard to look
at the numbers and make sense but then I
could still see that some of these
columns like carrot is highly correlated
with this XYZ
columns oh and even the price of course
the higher the carrot the higher the
price I guess it makes sense just trying
to you know put a visual representation
on top of this so I'm just creating a
mask to add it onto this you know
correlation DF and then plot them as
well this way it becomes a little easy
and clear to see you know price is
highly correlated with carrot and the
XYZ variables very similar here as
well and let's just of course you know
when the it it makes sense to have the
price and the carrot highly correlated
and one of the things is that we have we
currently trying to convert our you know
the snow park data frame into
pandas and then use that for the actual
You Know M plot and the other functions
because currently you cannot you know
like the snow part is not really support
the M plot Li and the other libraries to
plot it so I'm just converting them into
pandas and then passing the pandas data
frame to plot this you know scatter plot
and I can see that you know how as The
Carrot varies the price also varies but
it's not linear almost like an
exponential or like 2x function and just
like exploring what the different
columns in the data looks like but
primarily we were able to you know
transform the data by just encoding a
few columns and then scaling a car
column just also now overlooked what the
different features look like it makes
sense and once that is done we
also were able to write the
pre-processing pipeline back to snow
snowflake so now let's get into the
actual modeling part and before that let
me just clear the output it's easy for
us to follow through very similar again
we have the modeling API we using the XG
boost and the model selection to have
you know grid search survey for the
hyperparameter search we're also going
to use the model registry to store the
models now and again from the modeling
API I'm also I'm also using map as a
metric to optimize like to optimize for
and a very simple import we able to get
through then connection we were already
able to get all cool I'm setting the
scope again to the specific database and
the schema as well Life's good and okay
so now this is the actual training raw
data and then we did this you know some
of these are categorical columns some of
these are numerical columns so what is
the label output right so this is a
label column and what is the expected
output which is the predicted price now
we're going to you know calculate the
predicted price and compare it with the
price and then use the map error to see
how good the model predicted it and what
is the pre-processing you know file that
that we're going to use the one that we
already have
stored and it's just like the I guess
the classic boiler plate that we've
already you know figured out and now for
this one I'm going to be using an XG
boost regression model and let's see if
you're able to split the you know entire
data set into training and test set with
just 10% to the test set for me and once
that is done I'm going to create an xgp
regressor with whatever input columns
all of the categorical and numerical
columns or input columns and the output
is going to be the predicted price and
the labels that we have is the actual
price and let's just fit and predict on
the data set and once we have
that it you know runs for a few
seconds and we'll see what it looks
like I think while that is running let
me just look at
this oh okay okay so I see in the chat
that some of you are not able to connect
to snowflake through the notebook like
what errors are you running into where
you able to update the connection.
Json
all right so we were able to you know
fit and predict on the model and the
next step is
let's this is again just to show it's
not necessarily A Next Step but you can
if you had suppose trained your model on
pandas like using pandas data frames you
can pass pandas as an input to the
existing Snow Park Model as well so just
to show you like I can convert an
existing snow park frame into a pandas
data frame and I can still pass it to
the existing predict
[Music]
function okay and for the error that you
see are you updating the connection Json
with the right account identifier and
the password and the Account
Details all right like I showed again
even if you use pandas if you have your
data in the pandas format you could
still pass it on to the snow park
trained model as
well and let's just calculate the error
we have you know the result set from the
prediction so I'm going to use that
result along with the price and to
the the result set will be the predicted
price right so I'm going to use that to
create like calculate the map error and
what does that look
like okay it seems not so I mean very
close for some values and not so close
for a lot of values and like the value I
guess the map value itself absolutely is
007 and what what does it even mean so
can we just look at the actual versus
predicted values so we have an
understanding of what it looks
like H okay almost they really I guess
this feels like
a a good model like for the first
iteration it's I do see a lot a few
points up and below this kind of way off
the line but it's pretty much a good
deal otherwise so now this is again the
first iteration of the model just as any
other data science person let's go ahead
and run the you know hyperparameter
tuning part
where let's try to give you know a
couple of possible values that we want
to iterate with for the number of
estimators and the learning rate and
then we want to optimize the main the M
error and let's see how that comes to be
and if you're able to come up with what
the ideal
values for the estimator and the
learning rate
are and it takes a bit of
time
[Music]
all
right I all that is running I have a
quick
question
or okay I just put a poll out there are
you familiar with snowflakes like snow
park ML and the AI capabilities before
this one or is just
this all right this
is mm I see that some of us think now
that is super interesting to
learn so this one does take a few
seconds seconds maybe I could have cut
down on the number of values like
possible number of
values for the hyper parameters but then
let that run while it is trying to
identify you know the optimal model from
the given set of hyper
parameters let's you know like go ahead
and see what the further steps look
like and well currently because the we
still don't know what's the the the
final model is going to be but then in
the past when I had ran this oh okay so
we were able to run this successfully
this is great the grid search C we ran
and as you can see what does this best
estimator look
like there are no boosters nothing we
were only playing around with the
learning rate which seems to be 04 so
point4 is the optimal and what are the
number of estimators which is 500 okay
this
is what the best the best model
parameters are and I'm going to use that
to just you know plot my values
again for each of these you know number
of estimators and for the learning rate
what does the map error look like and if
you look at the you know graph of course
for the learning rate of 04 and with the
number of estimators 500 is where where
we get the least map error so I guess it
makes sense it's consistent with what we
saw
before and so I'm going to use that
model like the best estimator model to
you know to see what the map error is
actually for
that like use this price and let's just
see what it's going to be all right so
from 07 we were able to go to 06 it's
just like a very small difference but
you can see in terms of values as well
it's all a bit closer to the actual
price the predicted prices are and let's
just do another quick plot to see how
they look in terms
of I guess it's very similar not like I
guess at least to the human eye it's
hard to differentiate but maybe there
are a lot of points that are above like
which are far from the the line and you
can see here maybe it's little less
values over
there and here comes the fun part
deploying the ml model like
actually you know like building the
model pre-processing it creating
features and hyperparameter tuning and
is all like most of the data science
work but how do you actually deploy it
and store different versions of the
model along with its metadata for
inference is the mlop stuff so we have
model registry to help us here so so you
can use that optimal model like we can
say the optimal model is the best
estimator we got from the grid search
and then we're going to use the
estimators and learning rate we got from
there as well and we will create a new
DF from these the optimal learning rate
and the parameters that we got and let's
see what does that look
like and once we have that we can there
it's a two-step process to use a model
registry the first is to log the model
and the second is to actually deploy the
model and to log the model first I'm
going to use the training data and then
get the DB in the schema and Define a
model name whatever version for the
model that I want to keep and everything
and then I need to initialize the
registry because currently we don't have
any registry so let's go ahead and
initialize the registry with this
database and this schema and so I have
the model details which are defined here
and I have the registry here so let's go
ahead and log the model in that specific
registry and I also want certain metrics
to be captured which in our case is mean
absolute percentage error
M yes the model registry is in private
preview so it's just for us to
understand how it works
today awesome so we can just list the
models and see what it looks looks like
and currently the model registry
probably will have just nothing because
we only like deployed it oh we deployed
sorry we logged this model as well so
you can see that new model with the
metrics registration
timestamp and everything even the
environment specifications which you
used and more and once you have that so
currently we only have logged the model
and it is not ready for inference by
your consumers yet so we'll have to go
ahead and deploy a specific model and
for deployment you can always mention
what is the name of the model version
what do you want to call the deployment
and more and once you deploy that as
well whatever the deployment name you
using here you just need
to like say for example QA and prod and
staging and whatnot would be the
deployment
name
and the model name that you use you
could
just oh okay so it's taking a while to
deplo it's just a few seconds let's give
us that
time all right so once it's deployed
you're now able to see what was the name
and where was it deployed it's in a
standard warehouse the target method is
predict and what are the different
features it takes what is the output
feature it you know
produces and like where the model is
actually stored in a staging location
and all the details about the model is
now available now we deployed the model
now how do we actually use it at the
inference time to you know call the
model for
example and as you see here you create a
model reference from this registry this
model the specific version you create
that model reference and call it model
ref and you use this in the inference
time and just call the predict method
with with your input data
set and this is just to you know list
the models and see if it is there of
course it is
there and the deployment name is here
updated as well and at the inference
time you
just use that model reference and then
run predict on
that and in the end you can do the
cleanup and delete the deployment delete
the models and more but it's not you
know mandatory for us to clean it here
at least but you can you know clean it
in your own actual deployments if it's
not needed anymore and I've also added a
bunch of appendix stuff to you to go
through if you are working with if
you're a SQL person working with udfs
and store procedures and you want to use
the vectorized udfs deploy your models
you can do that as well for batch
prediction instead of
doing you know one row at a time for
example and I think this is pretty much
it for the workshop if you're able to
run through these different Jupiter
notebooks that that that brings us to
the end of it and you have this end to
end flow and I also wanted to like
quickly run
through like what next for
example
like whatever we talked so far is like
classical traditional machine learning
functions with psyit Lear and XG boost
and like whatnot then there is also
these tons of new llm features that are
available to you and if you want to
start working with llms and snowflake as
well you can check out the other
relevant quick starts that I have here
for
you and I guess that's pretty much it
thank you so much and I will leave this
quick start page for a few seconds for
folks who want to get started with
Advanced ml modeling because today what
we did was almost like a an end to
endend ml workflow but more like a 101
class not an advanced complex M workflow
but if you do want to get started with
Advanced workflows or llms refer to this
other quick start that we
have
and with this we are at the end of it
and I will get through any of
these questions at the
minute okay so I see some of the
questions with the problem connecting
to oh my God
okay
ah
okay some of us
have problems connecting to snowflake I
guess like if there is any connection
problem check your account identifier
which I see is the most common issues
for the connection Json and for the
other person error detecting the version
of lip
crypto is it
because oh okay so I see you're able to
like progress from one error to other
and keep going and let me know if you
have any other questions I guess I'll
give it about a couple more minutes uh
if you have any questions
or need link to any other resources I'd
be happy to help and otherwise thanks so
much for joining and it was great
presenting and learning more about M
with
snowflake you so much ven that was a
fantastic
Workshop thank you um can you show again
where to get the ID from you can get the
account identifier
from your snowflake account on the
bottom left if you click on the ID it
would ask you to copy the
identifier and you and you should
replace the dot with the hyphen in the
account
identifier and it will help you with
that maybe I should share the link to my
slides too